healthy eating doesn't have to be
complicated or you don't have to
sacrifice taste registered dietitian mia
sen is sharing some healthy meals and
snack ideas that taste great and take
just 20 minutes or less take a look
hey las vegas now eating healthy doesn't
have to be hard or take a lot of time
knowing how to quickly prepare
nutritious options is key for being
consistent with healthy eating habits
today i have meal and snack ideas that
take 20 minutes or less starting with
salads in a jar salad jars make for an
easy and nutritious grab-and-go lunch
option by following a simple layering
formula with dressing at the bottom and
delicate ingredients at the top you can
keep your salads fresh and crisp all
week long just pour it out onto a plate
when you're ready to enjoy start with
dressing at the bottom followed by
protein whole grains vegetables and
leafy greens for a plant-based twist i
use the like meat like chicken pieces
for the protein source which are ready
in minutes and perfect for throwing into
your favorite salad jars taco recipes
and burrito bowls these plant-based
chunks are gluten free packed with high
quality soy protein and are rich in
fiber plus each chicken piece has
authentic textures and are pre-seasoned
with flavorful spices you can find them
at sprouts and target
for an easy balanced dinner that's ready
in minutes try a simple stir fry with
whatever protein and vegetables you have
on hand this stir fry is made with a
mind-blown dusted shrimp by the
plant-based seafood company an
all-female family founded company with
20 years of experience in the seafood
industry now offering a sustainably
sourced alternative to traditional
seafood made 100 from plants the entire
mind blown plant-based seafood lineup
including the coconut shrimp dusted
shrimp and dusted scallops is free from
gluten dairy corn and palm oil and
tastes like the real deal you can find
the sustainably sourced alternative to
traditional seafood online at
plant-based seafoodco.com pair your
protein of choice with vegetables in
your fridge like broccoli bell peppers
and mushrooms with a stir-fry sauce and
cooked whole grain like brown rice or
quinoa to build a complete meal
for a fun and nutritious snack that
helps you meet your recommended one and
a half to two and a half cup servings of
fruit for the day try stuffed bananas
banana loca is a new innovative kitchen
gadget as seen on shark tank that
straightens a banana pours it while it's
still in its peel and allows you to fill
it with a variety of tasty and
nutritious food pairings start by
cutting off the tip of the banana use
the holder to straighten the banana and
use the core to remove the center add
filling to the hopper and press the
lever down to fill the banana for a
satisfying snack that pairs protein with
fiber filled with yogurt or nut butter
or for a nutritious dessert filled with
honey jams jellies or even nutella it's
an easy and fun way for kids and adults
to enjoy bananas a good source of fiber
and potassium you can find banana loca
bananaloca.com and on amazon
i hope you enjoyed this simple healthy
meal and snack ideas for more recipes
and nutrition tips you can visit my
website nutritionbymia.com
and instagram nutrition by